>> I think most of us would give the same answer.
The pitcher, not the backpack or the car or this box. Now for humans, for
you and me, this is a little bit of an easy problem.
All of us get it right pretty much all the time. And what about a machine?
What about a robot? How would a robot decide that a pitcher is a good utensil to
use for transporting soup from the kitchen to the dining table, but
not a backpack and not a box? For a robot, this is a surprisingly hard problem.
So the question then becomes, well, what is it that makes it easy for humans and
hard for robots? How can we program AI agents so that it would be easy for
them as well? One important thing to note here, this is another example of
incremental learning. Now we have come across incremental learning earlier,
when we were talking about incremental concept learning.
There we were given one example at a time, that was the example of art, and
we were learning one concept, the concept of art. This is in contrast to other
methods of machine learning. Where one is given a, large amount of data, and
one has to detect patterns with a variety in that data. Here,
there is learning occurring one step at a time, from a small number of examples,
one single concept has been learned. We also came across the notion of
incremental learning, when we were talking about chunking. Day two,
there was one particular problem, and from a small number of previous episodes,
we chunked a particular rule. This notion of incremental learning, for
me it's much of knowledge based AI. Another thing to note here, this notion or
expression based learning is related to creativity.
We talked earlier about the relationship between creativity and novelty.
Here is an example in which an AI agent is dealing with a novel situation.
Usual utensils for taking soup from the kitchen to
the dining table are not available. What should the robot do?
The robot comes up with a creative solution of taking the pitcher as the utensil